hat sich unser universum aus einem
schwarzen loch entwickelt oder tut es
das immer noch genau davon jedenfalls
gehen einige forschende aus
möglicherweise ist unser universum dann
aber auch nur eines von vielen und das
menschliche leben alles andere als
einzigartig klicks zum tanz im future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke denn nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
pixum gibt's übrigens auch auf die ohren
der link ist hier und ami und in der
video beschreibung geht man von der
klassischen urknalltheorie big bang aus
begann unser universum vor etwa 13,8
zwei milliarden jahren mit dem urknall
und damit entstanden gleichzeitig dann
raum und zeit dieser vorstellung zur
folge hat sich die frage was eigentlich
vor dem urknall war erledigt geht man
allerdings von der quantentheorie aus
sollte es doch ein davor gegeben haben
doch wie genau sah dieses davor aus und
woraus genau ist unser universum
eigentlich entstanden aus dem nichts
oder gar aus einem schwarzen loch wie
manche wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler mittlerweile annehmen
diese hypothese vertritt unter anderem
auch der polnische theoretischer
physiker nikodem poplawski er hält es
für möglich dass unser universum
vereinfacht gesagt mitten in einem
schwarzen loch entstanden ist war also
in dem augenblick in dem die gesamte
masse und energie des entstehenden
universums als eine art samen an einem
endlichen und unvorstellbar dichten
fleck vereint dieser samen müsste dieser
vorstellung zufolge sehr winzig gewesen
sein milliarden mal kleiner als jeder
partikel den wir menschen überhaupt
sehen können und doch hätte er es dieser
these nach geschafft nicht nur alle
galaxien sondern auch planeten und
lebewesen hervorzubringen solch einen
samen eines universums könnte man sich
so ähnlich vorstellen wie den samen
einer pflanze enthalten wären viele
essentielle substanzen und zwar stark
komprimiert und umgeben von einer
schützenden hülle und bei dieser hülle
könnte es sich um ein schwarzes loch
handeln heißt also im klartext dass
dieser samen im inneren eines schwarzen
lochs entstand
kleist in einem schwarzen loch ist die
materie unendlich dicht komprimiert und
die raumzeit deformiert heißt also
demnach könnte hier sogar die zeit still
stehen dazu sagt der kanadische physiker
lee smolin in dem moment in dem der
einsteinschen physik nach die zeit
stoppt greift die quantenmechanik und
ihre unscharfe der punkt an dem die zeit
in einem schwarzen loch endet verbindet
sich mit dem punkt an dem die zeit im
urknall eines neuen universums beginnt
der wissenschaftler hält es also für
möglich dass im inneren des schwarzen
lochs eine kleine region entstand die
sich inflationär aufblähte so entstand
also der keim eines neuen universums
doch nicht nur unser eigenes universum
könnte so entstanden sein
solch ein baby universum könnte sich
nach seiner entstehung nach außen hin
abteilen heißt dann aber auch im
klartext für unser universum auch dieses
könnte einmal in einem schwarzen loch
eines anderen universums entstanden sein
der kanadische physikers molin geht
deswegen davon aus dass es zahlreiche
parallelen universen gibt aus denen sich
wiederum baby universen abschnüren
das kann man sich wirklich kaum
vorstellen aber demnach könnte es
durchaus sein dass einige von uns ganz
unbemerkt zu einer keimzelle eines neuen
universums werden der theorie von smolin
zufolge vererbt dass eltern universum
sein baby universum auch den großteil
der physikalischen gesetze und parameter
doch auch hier könnten mutationen
auftreten was morin zufolge bedeutet
dass das baby universum durchaus über
eine geringere gravitation verfügen kann
oder aber ein bestimmtes
elementarteilchen leichter sein kann als
die seines vorgänger universums und
damit kommen wir zur sogenannten
multiversum theorie denn tatsächlich
astronomie teams weltweit diskutieren
schon seit einigen jahrzehnten darüber
dass nicht nur unsere erde sondern auch
unser gesamtes universum unbedeutend
sein könnte
zumindest im kosmischen maßstab demnach
könnten nämlich neben unseren eigenen
bekannten expandierenden universum noch
andere unzählige weitere existieren alle
jeweils mit ihren eigenen naturgesetzen
und achtung vielleicht sogar mit unseren
galaktischen doppelgängern statt einem
kosmos existiert dieser theorie zufolge
also ein sogenanntes multiversum der
russische physiker alexander will
beispielsweise glaubt an ein sogenanntes
ebene 2 multiversum in dem unzählige
organismen leben diese könnten
möglicherweise die selben namen tragen
wie personen auf unserer erde
nicht nur dass diese doppelgänger
könnten möglicherweise auch genau in
diesem moment auch genau dieses video
gucken
demnach ist das menschliche leben also
alles andere als einzigartig alexander
wie lenkt ihn stützt sich bei diesem
denken auf folgende annahmen
demnach kann das zwar unendlich viele
universen geben doch ist die anzahl der
möglichen zustände der atome und
elementarteilchen begrenzt und somit
auch ihre variationen demnach ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit also in einem
paralleluniversum das millionen
lichtjahre entfernt ist seinen
doppelgänger anzutreffen ziemlich groß
wobei millionen lichtjahre klingt ein
bisschen untertrieben
es müssten schon acht millionen und
abermillionen seien eigentlich
definieren also mit teams unseren
kosmischen horizont bei der optischen
grenze von 42 milliarden litern
doch es scheint keinen grund zu geben
warum das alles
genau dort aufhören sollte stattdessen
sind sich fachleute weitestgehend einig
dass jenseits des horizontes viele
vielleicht unendlich viele bereiche
liegen die dem unsichtbaren kosmos
ähnlich sind manche fachleute gehen also
zusammengefasst davon aus dass es völlig
unterschiedliche universum gibt das
ganze kann man auf das standardmodell
der kosmologie zurückführen nach der
sich das all unmittelbar nach seiner
entstehung ausgedient hat und dies auch
immer noch tut mancher region sind
demnach früher zum stillstand gekommen
als andere
sie haben sich quasi wie blasen in
kochendem wasser abgesondert bildlich
gesprochen natürlich und so wäre auch
unser universum nur eine blase
neben vielen weiteren dazu der
wissenschaftler allen gut
in einem universum das sich grenzenlos
inflationär aus dem passiert alles was
überhaupt passieren kann und zwar
unendlich oft jedenfalls würden sich
verschiedene universum gegenseitig
beeinflussen anfang 2018 hatte ein
forschungsteam aus großbritannien mit
einem supercomputer die expansion
unseres universums simuliert als das
modell dann der realität entsprach
veränderten die fachleute eine variante
und zwar die menge der dunklen energie
diese ließen sie gegen null sinken und
auf die 1
fachen werte unseres universums
ansteigen beide veränderung aber
beeinflussten die häufigkeit sowie die
art und weise wie sich sterne und
galaxien bilden nur unwesentlich mit
diesem ergebnis hatte niemand gerechnet
doch es macht die multiversum theorie
tatsächlich ein bisschen
wahrscheinlicher und zwar nicht nur dass
planeten und galaxien in anderen
universen existieren sondern auch dass
sich dort leben gebildet hat um also
konkret auf die frage zu antworten was
genau vor dem urknall wäre wäre die
antwort dann ein multiversum in dem
prozess zum urknall geführt haben
doch letztendlich ist die frage damit
auch nicht final geklärt denn mit dieser
theorie schließt sich eine weitere frage
wie ist dann dieses multiversum
entstanden gab es ein multi knall und
falls ja was war dann davor die idee des
multiversums stadt wirklich nicht
überprüfbar zu sein und deswegen gibt es
so großen widerstand gegen die theorie
der string physiker brian greene aber
hält es keineswegs für ausgeschlossen
dass wir eines tages belege für parallel
universen finden
ob es jahre jahrzehnte oder noch länger
dauern wird bis neue beobachtung und
theoretische fortschritte zu
detaillierten vorhersagen über ein
bestimmtes multiversum werden weiß
niemand kommen wir zurück zu der idee
dass universen in schwarzen löchern
entstehen könnten wie genau könnte
dieser samen also der anfang eines
universums zu stande kommen fachleute
die hinter dieser hypothese stehen
stellen sich das folgendermaßen vor
bei schwarzen löchern handelt es sich ja
um die überreste massereicher sterne
diesen geht irgendwann der brennstoff
aus und ihr kern fällt zusammen
die gravitationskraft ist enorm und das
gesamte gebilde wird immer fester
zusammengequetscht atomen und elektronen
werden zerfetzt und fest
zusammengepresst ihre überreste werden
immer weiter komprimiert somit wird aus
dem ehemaligen stern ein schwarzes loch
mit einem ereignishorizont vereinfacht
gesagt meinen die fachleute damit die
grenze zwischen der außenwelt und dem
inneren des schwarzen lochs ein weiterer
fachbegriff ist die sogenannte
singularität damit kann man ganz
vereinfacht den boden des schwarzen
lochs bezeichnen also einen punkt der
unendlich klein und dichtest manche
fachleute wie beispielsweise der
polnische physiker nikodem poplawski
halten es für möglich dass die materie
innerhalb eines schwarzen lochs
irgendwann ein punkt
an dem sie nicht weiter komprimiert
werden kann genau hier kommt dann der
samen ins spiel im gegensatz zur
singularität ist dieser demnach areal
vorstellen könnte man sich ihn zwar
unvorstellbar klein aber dafür mehrere
milliarden sonnenmassen schwer außerdem
ist ja auch enorm komprimiert und
verdreht zustande kommt dass durch unter
anderem die schnelle rotation der
schwarzen löchern das führt dann auch
dazu dass der verdichtung prozess zum
stillstand kommt die eigenschaften des
samens führen dazu dass es plötzlich
dazu kommen kann dass er aufspringt und
zwar mit einem knall poplawski zufolge
mit einem big bauens der wissenschaftler
hält es also für möglich dass ein
schwarzes loch eine art übergangszustand
zwischen 2 universum sein könnte eine
art verbindung so etwas wie eine
gemeinsame wurzel also im klartext heißt
das also bildlich gesprochen wenn ich in
das schwarze loch im zentrum unserer
milchstraße gelangen würde also wenn ich
rein fallen würde könnte es sein dass
ich in einem anderen universum wieder
herauskomme mal ganz abgesehen davon
dass ich dann natürlich ziemlich
zerfetzt wäre und von dem ganzen nichts
mitbekommen würde das ganze führt uns
zurück auf die anfangs fragen in diesem
video wie und voraus ist unser universum
entstanden demnach könnte es also das
produkt eines anderen universums sein
dass noch viel älter ist als unseres
eine art mutter universum also im
inneren eines schwarzen loches würde
dieser hypothese zufolge ja eine art
samen geschmiedet vor 13 8 milliarden
jahren kam es dann zu einem big points
also einem großen rückprall
möglicherweise befinden wir uns demnach
sogar noch immer hinter dem
ereignishorizont des schwarzen lochs
also im laufe dieser explosion wir sehen
immer noch nicht hinaus und das obwohl
sich ohne unser universum rasant
aussehen zusammengefasst lässt sich also
festhalten dass dieser vorstellung zur
folge vor unserem universum ein anderes
universum existiert hatte diese theorie
des zyklischen universums wird auch big
points genannt und das heißt so viel wie
großer rückprall demnach hat auch eine
kollision ein vorher und nachher heißt
aber auch dass wir uns von dem gedanken
verabschieden können dass der urknall
der anfang von allem sein muss darum
dass alles zu belegen müsste die
stringtheorie weiter ausgeklügelt werden
zudem bräuchte es belege der plan dazu
satelliten teleskope könnten demnächst
eventuell nachweisen dass die schwache
mikrowellenstrahlung also das echo des
urknalls in einem solchen zyklischen
universum andere eigenschaften hat als
in einem herkömmlichen big bang
universum urknall relikt entdeckt sehr
spannendes video natürlich denn es ist
von klicks ums tanzen future also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
diesen kanal hier klicks umsatz in
future es gibt keinen kanal mit so
vielen wissenschafts videos also bis
dann bleibt dran